[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce jeudi 9 novembre c'est la
journée nationale de lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire le phénomène
toucherait près de sept cent mille
élèves en france aujourd'hui à villiers
saint frédéric une centaine de lycéens
étaient formés pour devenir ambassadeur
sur le sujet et nous étions sur place
en novembre c'est le mois sans tabac
deuxième édition de ce défi collectif
pour arrêter de fumer dans cette édition
reportage au centre hospitalier de
versailles et nous recevrons catherine
quesnel du service prévention santé à
l'assurance maladie des yvelines la
ceppm propose un accompagnement pour
l'art et au tabac du tabac enfin faire
découvrir l'espace au grand public
ambitions de la série l'univers express
sur la chaîne youtube
bof eur/chf la première saison vient de
se terminer
on en parle avec son créateur cyril plus
mais avant de commencer les derniers
chiffres du tourisme ont été révélés par
aline c'est à la mi journée
bonne nouvelle la fréquentation est en
hausse en ile-de-france au troisième
trimestre de cette année + 11 % de
nuitées hôtelières dans la région par
rapport à la même période l'an passé à
la clientèle étrangère contribue
largement à cette augmentation
pas de retour pour autant au niveau de
fréquentation de 2015 avant les
attentats du 13 novembre
je vous le disais en titre c'est
aujourd'hui la journée nationale de
lutte contre le harcèlement à cette
occasion une centaine de lycéens à ses
formes et à villiers saint frédéric pour
dire non au harcèlement formation à
villiers saint frédéric bon pour devenir
ambassadeur et sensibiliser les
camarades à cette problématique du
harcèlement marie pannetrat et camille
lambert
enfin 5 mai lundi l'indicé
sept jours des plaques donc moqueries
répéter menaces violences sept cent
mille élèves de la primaire au lycée
serait victime de harcèlement un mâle
présent à l'école mais aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux qui peut mener à la
dépression et même au suicide
alerté par ce fléau maxime lycéens à
villepreux est devenu ambassadeur contre
le harcèlement
depuis un an il sensibilise ses
camarades il y avait une case seconde je
suis passé où il y avait un cas de
harcèlement d'un élève et s'avérer que
que cette classe a vraiment réussi à
prendre conscience sur harcèlement et
aujourd'hui quand on voit cette élève
qui est harcelé pour sur des motifs
assez physique ou voilà il est on le
sent déjà plus en confiance
comme lui une centaine de lycéens
souhaitent devenir ambassadeur à
villiers saint frédéric
ils ont participé à une journée de
formation organisée par le centre
académique d'appui aux écoles et aux
établissements et par l'académie de
versailles rôle d'un ambassadeur c'est
d'avoir des éléments clés sur la
thématique du harcèlement donc de savoir
ce qu'il ya derrière le harcèlement le
la victime et l'auteur finalement qui a
uni
d'une certaine manière est aussi victime
white et victimes abandonnées
comment peut l'aider comment peut
l'accompagner l'idée c'est ça c'est de
les amener à être acteur en fait auprès
de leurs camarades et pas seulement
spectateurs je trouve que c'est plus
fréquent qu'on qu'on le pense est
vraiment faim moi j'avais pas les outils
nécessaires pour voir agir et je
trouvais ça vraiment que grâce à ça
maintenant on est au courant et dès
qu'on est face à un cas de harcèlement
peut agir un soutien plus que nécessaire
et seulement 4% des élèves victimes de
harcèlement le signal de même on
rappelle ce numéro qui s'affiche en fin
de sujet c'est pour les enfants et les
familles des victimes d'harcèlement à
l'école le 30 20 services et appels
gratuits attrape la note la nationale 10
devrait être couverte à l'horizon 2021
les élus ont donné pour la deuxième fois
leur accord au financement de ce projet
d'enfouissement l' axe routier coupe
laville actuellement deux parties les
travaux sont estimés à 95 millions
d'euros
il devrait en coûter 9 millions à
trappes le reste sera financé par l'état
la région le département et saint
quentin en y
line premier coup de pioche prévus pour
l'an prochain on vous parlait il ya un
instant de la journée contre le
harcèlement scolaire c'est également en
ce moment le mois sans tabac 30 jours de
défis collectifs pour commencer à
arrêter de fumer
en france chaque année le tabagisme est
responsable de 75 mille décès et
direction le centre hospitalier de
versailles où il existe le csapa c'est
un centre de soins d'accompagnement et
de prévention en addictologie reportage
de mélanie poker vous aviez sas et 118
jours on avait calculé ram 160 jeunes et
si on met 40 ans et puis bah je me
sentais un petit peu prisonnier de la
cigarette
bon après aussi l'aspect santé mais
c'était surtout je me sentais
prisonniers
j'en avais marre que je n'éprouvais plus
de plaisir un fui 161 jours d'arrêt pour
mustapha ramdani après plus de vingt ans
de consommation de cigarettes
une décision prise en janvier après une
longue réflexion je me sens beaucoup
mieux donc je respire mieux j'ai pu
mener boucher j'ai un meilleur appétit
je dors mieux ça n'a pas été évident les
premiers mois étaient très difficiles
premiers mois les plus à risque de
rechute
bon après vous restez ex fumeurs on est
d'accord je
je dis je je combats mais dès la france
compterait de 16 millions de fumeurs 400
à 500 mille d'entre eux arrête de fumer
pour au moins un an
quand on fume ya trois dépendance et à
la dépendance physique à la nicotine est
où là le médecins ou les infirmières
peuvent aider avec des substituts ou des
médicaments il ya maintenant des
médicaments mais après il ya un tiers du
problème c'est psychologique comme
disait ce monsieur j'ai peur en
situation difficile de rechuter nous
pour me faire plaisir voilà
et puis à la dépendance comportementale
quand on s'ennuie
le tabac est responsable du décès
prématuré de plus de 75000 personnes
chaque année le mois sans tabac c'est
jusqu'au 30 novembre
quand on est soutenus tout devient plus
facile même arrêter de fumer
[Musique]
alors en novembre on arrête ensemble et
en équipe
et pendant le mois sans tabac
l'assurance maladie aussi se mobilise
bonsoir catherine quesnel bonsoir vous
êtes la responsable du service
prévention santé de la cpam des yvelines
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
la cpm qui propose un accompagnement aux
yvelinois pour arrêter de fumer on en
parle dans un instant en a trop et en
introduction rappelle le principe de ce
mois sans tabac 30 jours pour arrêter de
fumer c'est le défi lancé ça donc
en un mot un challenge en deux mots un
défi collectif
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de répondre à
une priorité de santé publique tant du
fait du nombre de décès liés au tabac
mais aussi parce que cette map 17
mortalité pourrait être évité donc le
ministère de la santé santé publique
france et l'assurance maladie a lancé
par l'intermédiaire de cette campagne
moi sans tabac un challenge tantôt
fumeurs qu'aux personnes proches pour
arrêter de fumer
et pourquoi un mois parce que c'est
justement après un arrêt d'un mois que
les chances augmentent de 5 fois
d'arrêter déficiences de chance
d'arrêter la reddition on s'arrête un
mois vous l'avez dit une initiative
lancée notamment par le ministère de la
santé auxquels la ceppm s'associent
pourquoi c'est important et pour les
assurances pour la science maladie de
s'associer à cette opération
alors pour les yvelines déjà c'est très
important parce que la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie est très soucieux de
la santé des yvelinois
et c'est une réelle priorité la
prévention santé donc
nous avons en place de ce fait un espace
prévention santé à guyancourt dans
lequel les yvelinois peuvent trouver une
équipe à l'écouté et qui peuvent les
conseiller et les accompagner
particulièrement ce mois ci à l'occasion
de cette campagne les accompagner pour
arrêter de fumer
l'assurance maladie propose aux
yvelinois de les accompagner de quelle
manière se met en place cet
accompagnement alors c'est tout d'abord
en rappelant les principes de base pour
arrêter de fumer
un projet bien construit une motivation
qui doit être présenté à son médecin
traitant
le médecin traitant est le premier
conseiller pour parvenir à la
réalisation de ce projet ensuite un
accompagnement par tous les dispositifs
également mis en place à savoir le site
tabac info service sur internet
également sur application mobile et via
une ligne téléphonique le 39 89 dans
notre espace nous avons également de la
documentation à disposition mais donc
accompagnement aussi qui concerne le
remboursement la cpam des yvelines
rembourse les traitements à base de
nicotine enfin pour trait pour trait les
bistrotiers nicotiniques tout à fait
donc c'est une disposition réglementaire
donc la cepam des yvelines comme les
autres ces femmes en france procède au
remboursement forfaitaire de 150 euros
par an et par bénéficiaire remboursement
150 euros quels traitements sont prises
en charge c'est vraiment ça ça va être
le patch l'est peut-être aussi des jeux
c'est pas des traitements différents
qu'elle quels seront ces traitements
d'accord alors déjà les traitements
médicaux donc les traitements médicaux
vont être conseillés par le médecin
traitant
à partir du moment où ces traitements
répondent au parcours de soins il y aura
une prise en charge rim ordonnance du
cou et une ordonnance pour les
substituts nicotiniques qui se présente
sous différentes formes mais dont le
traitement adapté sera effectivement
prescrit par le médecin traitant et 150
euros de remboursement par bénéficiaire
et parents ccd traitement général qui
coûte cher alors tout dépend d'eux
la quantité de tabac fumé donc de la
nature du sevrage pour un fumeur moyen
pour une période de deux mois il faut
compter à peu près 180 euros maintenant
la la dépendance de la dépendance
dépendra la durée du traitement
il ne reste déjà une minute dans cet
entretien pour allaiter arrêter de fumer
à côté de cet accompagnement il ya aussi
l'application
tabac info service elle propose aussi un
accompagnement personnalisé
comment ça fonctionne très rapidement
cette application alors cif c'est une
inscription très personnalisé où il faut
bien sûr introduire des données
correspondant à son profil c'est
accompagnant un accompagnement temps par
le fumeur que pour les proches et donc
ça permet aux fumeurs quand ya une
petite baisse de motivation durant le
mois et bien d'accéder à ses données sur
ce site
et de rappeler les réelles motivations
et puis également le soutien important
de ses proches
merci catherine quesnel d'avoir été avec
nous avec plaisir responsable du service
prévention santé à la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines la cpm
qui propose aux yvelinois d accompagner
pour arrêter de fumer et je rappelle
tout le mois sans tabac c'est jusqu'à la
fin novembre plus d'infos sur
l'application mobile mois sans tabac et
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran et dans l'actualité
également un rendez vous dédié aux
sciences du mouvement la 3e journée fait
d eve se tenait aujourd'hui à l'iut de
vélizy de l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines
feddev pour fédération des manies
vaucanson deux inventeurs des 18e et 19e
siècles
objectif fédérer les scientifiques et
présenter les recherches sur les
thématiques de la mobilité des
humanoïdes artificielle et sur les
interactions sociales et de grands
conférenciers réputés présents ce matin
olaf blanke et gordon ching présentation
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
le premier vient de genève et a fait
plus tôt on fait plutôt une conférence
autour des
de l'aspect cognitif donc le cerveau est
comme quels sont les mécanismes qui font
que l'on peut avoir l'impression qui est
un fantôme un être presque réel à côté
de soi donc là c'est vraiment pour
l'aspect cognitifs et le deuxième et
gordon cheng donc qui vient d'allemagne
c'est un professeur en allemagne lui qui
la travaille plutôt sur l'aspect
robotique humanoïde pour représenter
mécanique moi un être humain donc
modélisation de l'être humain et puis
réalisation de prototypes
la journée s'est poursuivie sur d'autres
conférences cet après-midi et se
terminent actuellement sur une remise de
prix
un chiffre qui marque les esprits dans
les yvelines 58 % des déplacements se
font avec un véhicule individuel
conséquence des axes routier saturé une
pollution récurrente selon les usages et
les transports collectifs ne sont pas
assez développés et sont peu efficaces
comment alors améliorer cette situation
objet d assises de la mobilité organisée
en ce moment un atelier territoriales se
tenait hier soir à versailles nicolas
qui l'habitent quelle place pour le
numérique dans les transports comment
réduire les fractures sociales et
territoriales lié aux mobilités des
questions vastes et complexes auxquels
ont tenté de répondre une cinquantaine
de personnes à versailles cet atelier
territoriale s'inscrit dans le cadre des
assises de la mobilité lancée en
septembre par le gouvernement
objectif imaginer et façonner les
futures politiques de transport chacun
des habitants à sa propre expérience de
mobilité et parfois ses propres
contraintes ou ses propres difficultés
et donc l'objectif c'est demande d'avoir
la concertation la plus large possible
arrivé à définir tout ça ensemble à
versailles élus locaux membres
d'associations et habitant plancher sur
deux thématiques précises
comment rendre les mobilités plus
connectés et plus solidaire de quoi
nourrir de nombreuses réflexions
on aimerait développer par exemple à 7,1
un système d'auto stop
organisé comme un système de covoiturage
sauf que l'on connaît les gens
et puis ça développe un lien social qui
s'est dégagée principalement concerne le
rabattement des villes et des airs
périurbaines sur les gares et les
centres lille avec toute une variété de
l'offre possible revaloriser d'avoir
plus d'informations sur
les transports disponibles que ces
informations soient disponibles de
manière unifiée sur une seule
application et qu'on puisse aussi dans
l'autre sens signifier sa présence les
assises de la mobilité se poursuivre en
france jusqu'en décembre
elles déboucheront sur un projet de loi
en début d'année prochaine
faire découvrir et comprendre l'univers
au grand public et aux plus jeunes c'est
le pari que vous avez pris cyril plus
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes yvelinois
fondateur du site d'actualités du ciel
et de l'espace
bof vous réalisez depuis le mois de mai
une série sur youtube qui s'appelle
l'univers express ces deux courts
épisodes pour bien comprendre l'espace
on en parle dans un instant votre
parcours d'abord parlons de ce parcours
vous êtes graphiste dans le documentaire
passé par l'école troisième de saint
quentin en yvelines d'où vient votre
passion pour l'espace
eh bien ça vient j'ai regardé un jour
dans une lunette astronomique et j'ai
trouvé ça a juste incroyable et voilà
derrière j'ai voulu approfondir en
découvrir davantage et et au bout d'un
moment le partager avec avec les et
pourquoi justement lancer cette série ce
site aussi d'actualité sur l'espace
avant finalement mettre à profit la
formation vous avez pu avoir à 3 yes la
mettre à profit dans ce genre de vidéos
en fait c'était vraiment ça je voulais
mélanger mon travail de graphiste avec
ma passion d'astronomie et je me suis
dit que ce serait intéressant du coup de
créer une série qui pourrait expliquer
aux gens ces phénomènes voilà de
l'univers d'une manière vulgariser donc
plus simple
la série qui est lancée depuis mai le
site all over pluie ça fait quelques
années déjà été créée fin 2016
alors depuis mais cette série à
l'univers express 2 à 3 minutes par
épisode pour faire comprendre l'espace
au plus grand nombre on regarde tout de
suite un extrait sur la formation des
étoiles et comment est née notre soleil
mais parfois un élément extérieur comme
une étoile supermassive en fin de vie
vient perturber la nébuleuse
une supernova est créé et provoque une
gigantesque comme de phoques
l'équilibré est rompu certaines parties
de la nébuleuse commence alors à
s'effondrer sur elle-même les gaz
commencent à se densifier la température
augmente d'une manière phénoménale
jusqu'au moment où une protoétoile
apparaît première étape de la formation
d'une étoile
la température encore de l'astre a
atteint les 10 mille degrés et c'est le
moment où les réactions nucléaires
s'enchaînent jusqu'à ce que l'astre se
stabilise et entre dans sa séquence
principale
tous venaient d'assister à la naissance
de notre soleil extrait du de ce premier
épisode de l'univers express inquiéter
consacré à la naissance des étoiles et
et plus précisément vous l'avez vu à la
naissance du soleil de notre soleil
alors cet épisode wii explique cette
naissance des étoiles on le voit d'une
manière assez ludique il ya beaucoup de
visuels et il ya de l'animation aussi
dans ces vidéos c'est quelque chose de
compos ressentir dans la vidéo oui
c'était vraiment j'ai voulu vraiment
prendre mon côté graphisme pour essayer
de faire quelque chose de ludique et
qu'ils puissent parler à tout le monde
parce que c'est vrai que ces sujets là
peuvent parfois être compliqué à
appréhender et voilà avoir des
animations des graphismes ça permet de
se soit plus ludique et plus simple à
comprendre
je vous le dis des sujets compliqués
c'est vrai l'univers comprendre l'espace
et des choses compliquées pourtant on y
vit dans cet univers j'imagine aussi que
c'était important pour vous de bien
faire comprendre d'apporter ses
connaissances de manière ludique pour
comprendre l'univers
c'était important oui effectivement
c'est c'est très important parce qu'il
peut avoir des a priori on peut penser
que c'est très scientifique très
compliqué ce qui parfois est vrai et du
coup le ramener la menée d'une manière
plus enfin vulgariser d'une manière plus
ludique plus accessible aux gens c'est
ça c'est important parce qu'il ya une
magnifique choses à découvrir
et c'est compliqué à vulgariser ce genre
de sujet ça dépend vraiment les sujets
la naissance d'une étoile ça peut encore
aller mais il ya certains sujets comme
les trous noirs j'ai fait un épisode
dessus où j'ai travaillé avec des
astrophysiciens de l'observateur de
paris ou du cnes ont aidé à comprendre
moi-même ce sujet avant de de
l'expliquer vous parlez du cnes l'agencé
spatiale française il ya un vrai
partenariat qui s'est mis en place pour
ses vidéos
c'est ça oui sur la première saison il
relayait tous mes épisodes sur leurs
réseaux et là on est en train de mettre
en place pour la deuxième saison
un partenariat un petit peu plus aboutie
pour parler de deux projets sur lesquels
je travaille aussi
mais certaines vidéos on l'a vu
d'ailleurs avec cette naissance du
soleil
il ya parfois aussi une traduction en
anglais c'est aussi important qui est
ouest est double langue finalement
français l'anglais en sous-titré oui
parce que l'univers de toute façon c'est
universel ça parle à tout le monde et
voilà j'ai malheureusement pas le temps
de faire tous les épisodes en anglais
parce que ça prend un certain temps mais
j'espère à termoli pouvoir tout traduire
en anglais également alors la saison une
de l'univers express vient de se
terminer
douze épisodes c'est ça ou 13 produits
saison 12 épisodes sur la première
saison avec en point d'orgue l'interview
de thomas pesquet il était l'invité
on va dire vedette du douzième épisode
oui c'est ça ma loch ness m'avait invité
à toulouse
ils ont un centre là bas et pour
l'occasion j'ai rencontré thomas et je
faisais un épisode sur le village
lunaire donc j'ai pu rencontrer thomas
thomas pesquet et lui parler lui poser
des questions directement sur ce sujet
là
comme vous voyez en images un le
spationaute thomas pesquet première
saison la volonté là c'est d'en faire
une deuxième
peut-être une troisième si ça continue
de marcher comme ça marche jusque là
voilà il n'y a pas de date limite pour
l'instant juste revenons sur comment ce
monde ces vidéos il ya beaucoup
d'animation c'est ça et la préparation à
ce fait comment de ces vidéos
d'abord je fais beaucoup de recherches
sur le sujet j'écris un scénario que je
fait valider par des astrophysiciens
quand j'ai un doute ou quand c'est
compliqué ensuite georges eastman voix
off et derrière je fais mes animations
en rythme avec la voix off par dessus et
pour la saison 2 il ya quelques pistes
de sujets déjà qu'il ya des pistes de
sujet on va on va parler d'eux
d'exploration spatiale beaucoup
notamment avec le cnes voilà puis de
plein d'autres phénomènes dans l'univers
beaucoup de la planète rouge mars
également d'accord et on a on est une
date pour peut-être la sortie du premier
épisode wii début janvier j'aimerais
bien le temps de travailler un petit peu
dessus en décembre jean novembre
décembre et début janvier
l'idée c'est de rester aussi sur deux
épisodes par mois comme vous faisiez
pour voir la première saison oui un
épisode toutes les deux semaines
j'aimerais bien et vous pouvez retrouver
tous ces épisodes sur la chaîne e bonne
heure fait également sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci beaucoup si elle persiste avec
nous réalisateur de la série à l'univers
express est à retrouver bien sûr sur la
chaîne et youtube
rob huff et jusqu'à l'an prochain c'est
le centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale et pour la troisième année
consécutive et les clayes-sous-bois
commémore l'événement qui a fait près de
18 millions de morts thématique choisie
par la ville la place des femmes dont la
grande guerre une exposition est à
découvrir à l'espace philippe noiret
qu'on voit ça avec camille lambert aux
champs ou dans les usines des munitions
au tricot le rôle des femmes pendant la
première guerre mondiale a été
essentielle un hommage leur est rendu
aux clayes-sous-bois édite le poivre a
réalisé ses sculptures pour l'occasion
les hommes étaient partis au front et il
fallait continuer à vivre normalement et
faire vivre les villages les villes etc
donc j'ai voulu représenter tout ce
travail que les femmes ont fait à la
place des hommes il y a une histoire
mais je crois quand on plonge dedans
comme je lé fais au travers de ce
tableau et les précédents les couvre
beaucoup de choses et j'ai vraiment une
beaucoup d'admiration beaucoup
d'admiration pour ces femmes
cela fait trois ans qui dit participer
au centenaire 14-18 des clayes-sous-bois
un événement pour transmettre la mémoire
dans des conflits les plus meurtriers de
notre histoire
l'exposition mise en place à l'espace
philippe noiret retrace plusieurs
facettes du rôle des femmes
l'occasion de découvrir qui est elle est
marraine de guerre
la marraine de guerre c'était ces femmes
qui faisait des
des colis et des lettres qu'ils
adressaient et qui était adressé aux
soldats sur le front pour embellir entre
guillemets leur quotidien on a aussi ses
apports visuel qui permettre qui
permettent de mettre des images sur des
mots sur des choses dont on a entendu
parler ça aide les enfants à mettre des
images
ils sont toujours très curieux aussi de
voir des objets exposition accessible
jusqu'au 19 novembre
la soirée de lancement du centenaire 14
18 est prévue en compagnie des filles
aux mains jaunes le 10 novembre
une plongée dans le quotidien des obus
êtes ces femmes qui fabriquait les obus
jusqu'à en avoir les mains jaunes
si on sortait de dimanche
un culture toujours c'est une création
de la compagnie o'navio flanc plomb et
musette
adapté d'un album illustré à del et
byetta ça parle de la guerre et de la
séparation avec l'utilisation d'ombrés
chinoises et de doudou spectacles
proposés à la ferme de bel ébat mélanie
poquet a assisté à une représentation
scolaire musette et flonflons ce sont
eux deux enfants amis inséparables un
peu amoureux qui subit ces décisions des
grands à l'origine un album death byetta
auteurs jeunesse j'ai l'impression ça
c'est pas parce qu'on fait de l'art du
théâtre jeune public ne peut pas parler
de sujets graves
c'est un c'est un livre qui en parle
dans ce cas c'est une histoire qui parle
de ces sujets là de la guerre la
séparation qui on parle aussi beaucoup
de joie et espoir voilà cet accès malgré
un sujet un peu difficile c'est pour moi
c'est un spectacle noir
flonflons et musette dure une trentaine
de minutes où les personnages sont des
petits doudou lapin c'est sûr que nos
questions d'anticipation en fait
l'enfant peut identifier l'objet assez
assez facilement et le fait que ce soit
des doudous des lapins ça c'est moins
choix de l'auteur est le méta je crois
que la distance aux 6 à 17 ans en ciel
propose certes c'est pas vraiment des
enfants voient ce sont deux ça ça reste
des animaux qui ont des comportements
des comportements un seul en scène
délicat à découvrir dès l'âge de 4 ans
un moment plein de tendresse
petit rappel avant de refermer ce
journal le deuxième festival play for
humanity se tient demain et cinq samedi
c'est au scarabée de la verrière de
soirée concert en faveur notamment de
l'association française des victimes du
terrorisme
l'édition précédente avait rassemblé
1000 spectateurs pour 9500 euros de dons
reversés au final c'est la fin de ce set
8 journal merci de l'avoir suivi retour
dès lundi à l'antenne vendredi vous
retrouvez le 7-8 l'hebdo présenté par
nicolas kirillovitch qui revient sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale de la
semaine et ce journal il est bien sûr
disponible en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]